aquí nos dicen que la tabla muestra el
número de personas que esperan en una
fila para subirse a diferentes juegos en
un parque de diversiones 15 personas
esperan para subirse a la montaña rusa 4
personas esperan para las sillas locas
12 personas esperan en la fila para
subirse a los carritos chocones y 11
personas esperan para el carrusel cuál
es la razón entre las personas esperando
en la fila para subirse al carrusel y
las personas que esperan para subirse a
las sillas locas pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo queremos conocer la
razón entre las personas que esperan en
la fila para subirse al carrusel con
respecto al número de personas que
esperan para subirse a las sillas locas
vamos a ver aquí hay 11 personas
esperando para subirse al carrusel y hay
4 personas esperando para subirse a las
sillas locas así que la razón es 11 a 4
por cada 11 personas
qué esperan para subirse al carrusel hay
cuatro personas esperando subirse a las
sillas locas hagamos otro ejemplo
karina ama leer en los últimos meses ha
leído tres novelas románticas dos de
misterio cuatro de ciencia ficción y 21
cómics cuál es la razón entre las
novelas de ciencia ficción y los cómics
nuevamente pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta vamos a ver
queremos conocer la razón que hay entre
las novelas de ciencia ficción ella ha
leído cuatro novelas de ciencia ficción
y los cómics ella ha leído 21 cómics
entonces la razón es que por cada cuatro
novelas de ciencia ficción ella tiene 21
cómics por lo tanto la razón es 4 a 21
la razón de novelas de ciencia ficción
con respecto a los cómics es de cuatro
novelas de ciencia ficción por cada 21
cómics hagamos otro ejemplo esto es
divertido cuál es la razón entre
manzanas y plátanos 2 en el vídeo y
traten de resolver
vamos a ver aquí tenemos una dos tres
manzanas entonces por cada tres manzanas
cuántos plátanos tenemos bueno tenemos
uno dos tres cuatro plátanos así que la
razón de manzanas con respecto a los
plátanos es de tres manzanas por cada
cuatro plátanos aquí el orden es muy
importante porque si nos hubieran
preguntado por la razón entre plátanos y
manzanas entonces esto habría sido 4 a 3
pero como nos dicen manzanas y plátanos
la razón es de tres a cuatro tres
manzanas por cada cuatro plátanos hemos
terminado nos vemos en otro vídeo